in Ran said that truth is the
recognition of
reality and what we are experiencing is
a war on the
truth just let's look at anoir alaki for
a second because I think that this
crystallizes the problem down to its
essential oils anir alaki was the go-to
Imam by The Washington Post by the New
York Times by the major media networks
when 9/11
occurred he was the to Imam for all
things Islam he was invited to the
Pentagon not just for lunch but for
dinner at the same time the exact same
time he was the spiritual uh adviser to
three of the Muslim terrorists who had
attacked uh our country on 9911 and here
we are and I I I I I couldn't help but
pull this because this is today's New
York Post not a lefty
newspaper uh who says in it but after
9911 things changed and he became angry
at anti-muslim
backlash okay so this is now after we
know that anir alaki was a spiritual
guide um uh guider uh advisor to the 911
terrorists we know there was no mayaula
by the washing by the uh well the
Washington Post did say that they
thought he was moderate uh but no Maya
Cula like look this is the war the war
is very tricky here is a man who said
here he said this is what he said to the
media after 911 he said our hearts bleed
for the attacks that targeted the World
Trade Center when the man had a hand in
it so it's a tricky deceptive War and
why is that I'll tell you why that is
because Muhammad said war is
deceit and it's very important that you
understand that
propaganda is the stealth Jihad it is
the most important component and we have
a media that's complicit I believe
criminally negligent at this
point a media that is Sharia
compliant Sharia
compliant you have an Iranian
Pastor who is going to be put to death
because he will not revert back to Islam
and in none of the news stories do they
say that this is the Sharia
they say this is Iran well what is Iran
Iran is the Islamic Republic of Iran
they're living under the
Sharia never the 2 million that are
slaughtered in the Islamic genocide in
Dar war and Sudan you ever hear it
referred to as a Jihad no when the south
southern Sudan Christian Sudan voted on
a referendum 90 was it 99% voted for
Independence Did anyone say they voted
to secede from the Islamic North no the
Jihad against
Israel the Jihad against that's what it
is this is not about Land look at a map
enough already they ever show a map in
the context of the of the map there is
Israel nine miles at its wide if if uh
the UN has its way surrounded by
ginormous Muslim
lands and it's about land they think
you're
stupid and everybody's shaking their
heads like
bobbleheads the war on the truth is at
every level in New York City the New
York City transit authorities running
ads calling for the end of us Aid to
Israel they're running these
ads stop us Aid to Israel as if as if
the US supporting an ally in the defense
of its very existential
being is an impediment to
peace as if Israel's at war with
anybody Israel is trying to save her own
life it's pure and simple self-defense
so of course I submitted my own
ads as
I took come down my
trademark and my ad said this in any war
between the Civilized man and the
Savage support the Civilized man support
Israel defeat Jihad
now let me say two things first of all I
was told I couldn't get on the subway
trains for less than
$36,000 I said wow cuz I have in my
wallet I think 5 cents um I said could I
do the buses then ever since I did my
ground zero mosque bus ads and my
leaving Islam bus ads to again rebut the
prosti for Islam bus ads they change the
buy now you can't buy $88,000 worth now
the minimum buy in the buses is 50K
but if you buy the tals it's 20 so I
said okay I I'll buy the tals whatever
my ads were
rejected they would not run my ads
because of the word
Savage understand the MTA has run ads
against the Tea Party Manhattan moving
in storage they run these ads making fun
of the Tea Party running making fun of
Bachman making fun of Palin they're
making fun of Republicans making fun of
everybody but I can't
use the accurate term of savage because
any Act of war against innoc innocent
civilians is savagery plain and
simple the Fogo family is not savagery
keeping jalad shal in a Hamas torture
chamber and dungeon for six years
without one visit from the red course is
not
savagery the war against Israel in the
summer of 2006 well I should say the war
against Israel since its establishment
since 1948 is not savagery the the
denial of Israel's right to exist is not
savagery so I filed a lawsuit against
the MTA they were served the day before
yesterday and I can tell you that I will
take it to the Supreme Court because
once you decide to make a public uh
government agency decides that they're
going to allow their public forum for
political speech then you don't get to
decide what you like and what you don't
like you don't decide what's good and
what's forbidden because political
speech is the most protected speech
under the First
Amendment who decides
Obama the UN which increasingly this was
in my first book The post- American
presidency the Obama administration's
war in America we have in this President
among other things um a a a uh an anti-
leer meaning he has relinquished
American sovereignty relinquished
American hedgemon at the UN to the UN to
international law why is this so
critical because the UN is being driven
by the organization of Islamic
cooperation it was called Islamic
conference now I guess it's supposed to
be more warm and fuzzy like
cooperation um 56 Muslim countries plus
the Palestinian Authority why do you
think every resolution is against Israel
why do you think every resolution is
anti-American why haven't there been
resolutions against our four uh the
Congo Ethiopia the piracy what is the
piracy outside of Somalia it's Jihad
it's the same barbery pirates that we
were fighting against in not the first
not only the first barbery war but the
second barbery war the first war that
America fought against a foreign power
was a war against Islamic Jihad are you
taught this in school are your children
taught this in school do you know what
children are taught in school you won't
believe what your children are taught in
school again part of the islamization of
America these curriculums and I took a
lot of heat for exposing Rick Perry's
curriculum he instituted a
curriculum with the aacon it was
extensive I took screen I said don't
believe me because the right really tore
into me they went after me viciously uh
cuz they liked him somebody up there
somebody up there decided he's the man
and so I ran the curriculum all the
lessons look at yourself complete da
complete whitewashing of Islam and I
called him out on it now look on godil
with the Mandate on the uh cervical
vaccine he did a mayaula but he didn't
do a May Cula on the curriculum and I'm
telling you this is a key issue this is
a key issue and one that the candidates
don't want to touch look it's very easy
to say low taxes small government
limited government
it's a no brainer but what good is your
wallet if you don't have your head and
you don't have your freedom and every
single day it's Chip Chip chipping away
just this week in Georgia there was a
curriculum uh in it was in cop County it
was in um Marietta uh one parent
objected because this the story was my
name is AA and a Lima uh is uh loves the
burka and feels so sorry for the
horribly modestly dressed Western women
loves the fact that she's wife number
two because you know wife number one is
much more social and likes to go out to
dinner but I like to be at home I'm a
I'm a stay-at-home girl so it's really
great uh that uh there's more than one
wife and even if you know even if he
doesn't prefer you you're always taken
care of and this is how it's presented
and at the end she goes we are so
fortunate for this
Sharia and this is to seventh
graders and it's always under the guise
of we have to understand other cultures
really I don't have to understand
beheading I don't have to understand
misogyny I don't have to understand
oppression I don't have to understand
the subjugation of non-muslims and women
under any circumstances I don't care
about the religious aspect of the thing
there are a lot of people that Rel that
worship a lot of freaky things we're in
America you're allowed to do that but
once you try to impose it upon me this
is where that we have to draw the line
in the sand and it is a tricky battle
because as soon as you take up this
mantle you are racist Islam obic
anti-muslim bigot even though of course
Islam is not a race but why split hairs
you're being manipulated just go along
with it and this is what they're trying
to do even the right tea party even
though they've stayed away from this
issue the Tea Party are extreme what
does that mean what is Extreme except a
a a measurement a measurement is it not
a measurement is is Extreme health and
extreme disease equally undesirable
is Pursuit Of Truth in the extreme a bad
thing is pursuit of Freedom a bad thing
in the extreme it's a lie it's a smear
don't buy it don't buy it don't let them
stop
you in this room in this room I see the
future in this room I see the future of
America uh you're all to be commended
for being here each and every one of you
because this is not an easy battle you
have everything against you just like we
had everything against us at the ground
zero mosque we did we had a mayor that
colluded with the ground zero
Musketeers we had a mayor who filled out
the applications who filled out the
applications and helped them write their
letters to the Lower Manhattan committee
yeah we had a President Who at the ifra
dinner stood up and said they they they
should build it we had everyone the
media were names Gamal NBC person of the
year and just the other night on PBS
they did such a boot looking puff piece
on gal never mentioning his bank default
of not one but two bank loans never
mentioning the quarter of a million
dollars that he hasn't paid in back tax
is the dead beat that he is never
mentioned his rap sheet or his uh you
know um episodes with prostitutes blah
blah blah but he's a man of great honor
and respect because he wants to build a
15 story Mega mosque in a building that
was destroyed in the 911 attacks on
burial
ground but he's not building
it he's not building it yeah it's now
went from 15 stories to 10 stories to
eight stories to now it's five stories
soon it'll be in the
basement it doesn't belong there it's a
cultural obscenity and it's a 15 story
middle finger to America that's what it
is and if you didn't know it then you
know it
now so my point in all this is that
public opinion is very important
you won't win everything and I assure
you we haven't won this one they'll be
back oh yeah they want this they want
this because we have to understand that
symbolism is very
important iconography in Islam is
critical and the ground Zer mosque is
the mother of all
symbols there has never in the history
of Islam ever been a mosque of
reconciliation and heing healing on the
site of a Jihadi attack ever but there
are tens of thousands of Victory mosques
on the cherish sites of conquered lands
Dome of the Rock is the first temple and
the second temple in in Jerusalem the
most of holiest sites to the Jewish
people the St Sophia the most Exquisite
and gorgeous Church in the world is a
mosque tens of thousands of Hindu
temples so we know and they know that we
know and that's why you have to be
destroyed they don't want you to learn
about Islam they don't want you to and I
again will tell you a 100 times I have
no problem with Muslims I love them I
have a problem with the extreme and
radical ideology that inspires Jihad
period
Kudos kudos to
bre
yes because that is
infiltration care was named as an United
co-conspirator in the largest Hamas
funding trial in our nation's history K
was named as a Muslim Brotherhood proxy
K is very upset that Anar alaki was
killed now the problem that I have with
anori now I have blogged on him for
years I know exactly who and what he is
he is a spiritual leader to uh religious
and devout Muslims uh the fact that
again you see they always say we don't
know what happened to him he was a
lovely boy and the neighbors said oh
wonderful
neighbor a lovely boy who what happened
he became religious that's what happened
happened to him so here you have Obama
now you could you know here you have
Obama going
in killing this man and at the same time
you
have major nidal Hassan the for Hood
jihar who made a presentation on Grand
rounds came out on Grand rounds a
brilliant PowerPoint presentation on
Jihad I use it sometimes if there's a
machine who was wearing the Garb of the
Shahid the morning of his Jihad who was
giving out qurans the morning of his
Jihad who was screaming Al abbar while
he mowed down 13 and there was a
pregnant woman 14 of our soldiers and
wounding 32
more and by the way ALU abbar means
Allah is greater Allah is greater
greater than what greater than your God
just so that you understand what they're
saying and Obama the Obama
Administration won't release the
evidence on major Hassan he has a he has
a Jihadi who killed American
soldiers who's still getting paychecks
and the two civilians the two cops that
took him down have been laid
off but he's going over there and he's
killing on waraki and Samir Khan Samaran
was a he was a jihadist blogger is what
he was he came out with the slick
magazine Al qaa not saying that it was
wrong to kill them you know how I feel
you know who I am but I'm saying you
want to try KH Shake Muhammad in a New
York Court foreign born give him all the
constitutional rights afforded to a
American citizen and his merry band of
killers this he's putting his foot down
he wants to prosecute our CIA agents
that got the information three three
three three terrorists were were boarded
three saved Los Angeles a terrorist
attack of thousands but you want to give
them uh due process but you're gone and
you're you know you're just killing over
there I want to understand the
epistemology I want to understand the
premise I want to understand how what is
the
policy you the Department of Defense
issued the report on the for Hood Jihadi
in not one report the final included was
religious
motivation ideology or motive mentioned
not
once how are you going to defeat an
enemy that you are afraid to name right
on the anniversary of 911
the president of the United States
issued guidelines to official ceremonies
both here and abroad
specifically directing these various uh
commemorative C ceremonies not to
mention Al qaa not to mention religious
motivation not to mention
ideology okay this is 10 years after 911
but a day later he issued a specific and
credible threat from who Mr President
Mickey
Mouse when I was a kid in
school I learned about December 7th I
learned about Pearl harb day I learned
that we were a nation United and our
resolved to defeat the enemy and 10
years after December the 7th the Germans
and the Japanese were vanquished 10
years after
911 they're instituting in the school
curriculums a 911 uh lesson and it's all
about service it's all about healing
it's all about reconciliation nowhere is
the enemy
mentioned think about this and all
across the colleges were what are you
doing for service it's a day of service
it's all about service what are you
doing for service excuse me look service
is a fine thing but not on 911 no 911 is
our day of mourning morning a terrible
day in American history you must never
forget those people choosing between
being burned to death or flinging
themselves out of Windows hundreds
hundreds hit the ground with a sound you
will never forget never
forget the islamization of America is
imposing Islam on the secular
Marketplace what do I mean by that the
masking of the workplace let's say
imposing Muslim prayer times on Union
contracts forcing non-muslim workers to
lengthen their day the hin company the
hindes company you know the ketchup
company at condiments has been
extraordinarily generous in their
accommodation to their Muslim workers
they have Muslim prayer rooms they have
Muslim prayer rugs and what happens when
you accommodate demands for more
accommodation they're going to be sued
hin is going to be sued to stop the line
stop the line for Muslim prayer times
now I'm going to tell you Muslim
countries under the Sharia they don't
stop the line they don't stop working no
they make it up before or after so why
this to impose Islam on the secular
Marketplace that's why the public
schools setting aside uh pray space
they're not doing it for Christian kids
they're not doing it for Jewish children
they're not doing it for Hindus they're
not but they are putting aside the
special spaces for Muslim prayer and of
course the curriculums are very scary so
when Rick Perry institutes a curriculum
nine lessons very intense very
extensive and doesn't issue a May Copa I
got a problem with that Governor Perry
are you instituting a Christian
curriculum are you instituting a Jewish
curriculum do not make the school a
religious Battleground
now It's Tricky and this is what I get
to my book if this is happening in your
school you go in there and say look I
don't want this talk to my kid they're
going to say oh that parent that
parent's a bigot that's not what you do
for every time they bring in someone
someone from care and Care like in
Pulley up pulley up care wanted to go
into the pully up school district and
explain about Islam the thing to do is
if they're going to bring in an Imam or
someone from K or isna all the 300
groups that were named in the in the
largest Hamas funding
trial all of them um it's interesting to
me that before Ani became the president
of the Muslim Student Association at his
university he was a benign he was a
secular Muslim the Muslim Student
Association and student union was named
as a virent uh Muslim Brotherhood group
in that trial as well it's interesting
to me you have to demand that a priest
come
in and a rabbi come in to talk about uh
you know how Judaism is The Godfather of
monotheism and how his life was changed
when he went to visit the cotel I don't
care you're going to demand because that
they don't want so instead of saying
listen this is not right say we for
every and get yourself a holy a seek
holy man get yourself a Hindu holy man
you go bring yourself a whole Mod
Squad yeah that's what you're going to
do you're going as a man equal
time and you're as a man you're going to
read those lessons you have to look and
if you don't have children you have
grandchildren tell your grandchildren
they come over and you're going to make
them lockers or whatever it is you do
with them to bring their history book
you want to see it is the MU discussed
in their history books is the MU is the
role of Islam during the Holocaust ever
discussed is the leader of the Muslim
world who is responsible for the death
of 400,000 women and children ever and
ever mentioned no why because it's
whitewashing Islam which by the way is
the Sharia under the Sharia it is
blasphemy to offend criticize or assult
Islam even if it's the truth and who is
enforcing this the OIC the organization
of Islamic conference who do you think
was behind the prosecution the attempted
prosecution of hered builders in in
Holland they are very influential in the
UN they are very influential in the
EU they are in effect while they may
look like a transnational bureaucracy
they are in effect the modernday
caliphate and they exercise enormous
power
now it's up to us to keep this country
free and that means for all Muslims that
leave Muslim countries escaping the
Sharia oh yes there's a lot of those oh
the media never let you hear about them
you never hear from rahil razza who was
uh against the ground zero mosque or you
know the the the cab driver whose face
was slashed they first started to say
that was a you know an anti an anti-
mosque person but that story got got
quiet fast you know why it got quiet
fast cuz the guy that slashed him was
affiliated with the mosque and the camp
driver who was Muslim was against the
mosque many Muslims of conscience
understood why it was deliberately
provocative deeply offensive and
insulting and
disrespectful this idea now people say
oh you paint all Muslims with a broad
brush no I don't no it's not
so but I don't have to congratulate
somebody for not wanting to kill
me am I wrong
I don't have to pat on the back somebody
who doesn't want to kill me that's my
bar I expect that you don't want to kill
me I don't believe that every German was
a Nazi either I don't either the point
is there is a radical ideology that
inspires Jihad the point is there had
been close to 20,000 Islamic attacks
since 911 each one with the inber matter
of a Muslim cleric and the violent Jihad
is not even what it worries me it's the
stealth Jihad the mking of the
neighborhood when you see in a quiet
small town on a quiet street a monster m
going up built by the Muslim Brotherhood
you have every right to protest that
amen every single
right and in this
book in this book I teach you how to do
that I because you have to remember as
soon as you walk out of your house the
camera is on the television camera is on
and they're just looking to catch you in
a moment I'm sure I bre it was what was
there may have been one person who said
something stupid and then the whole
story becomes about that one person who
said something
stupid he can't be
stupid this is an enemy that has
perfected this over centuries the only
religion with a propaganda
on it's very smart it's all it has ever
done if you want a cautionary tale look
to Europe if you think that's not what's
happening what why all of this like
agitation over these Sharia
legislations who would not be against
the most extreme and radical ideology on
the planet now you could say Pamela
that's not happening it's not I tell you
there's an attempt to restrict free
speech I tell you that attempt is under
the guise of hate speech laws why was my
ad
denied they said I was offending Muslims
where in that ad am I defending Muslims
by calling the enemy of Israel the
terrorist against Israel s
they are now it's the truth now there's
a war on the truth my leaving Islam
ABS I had to sue Detroit they would not
run my leaving Islam ads they were exact
same ads as the prosing for Islam except
said leaving Islam is there a fatwa on
your head is your a family threatening
you those ads were inspired by RI gabar
a Christian cover out of Islam and I
happen to be covering a trial and while
I'm coming to tr I see these bus heads
going by prizing say what about the
Muslims that want to leave and they are
Muslims that want to leave and there is
no safety net and the media won't talk
to
them and we do help get them to safe
houses are they not entitled are they
not entitled to be free what's with the
special rights for Islamic
supremacists why are we allowing that to
happen you cannot allow this to happen
you must get involved you must play the
game you must go to those Town meetings
those City Council meetings when they
you know again they smooze the city
council board oh we just want to build
it three stories high and this wide in
this and a giant thing and if it was a
synagogue if it was a church if it was a
Walmart if it was a Lowe's they would
never get approval never in a million
years but again it's always a special
accommodation always hate speech laws
are the scariest aspect of this whole
fight because freedom of speech is what
keeps us free I don't care
that's I don't care if you march the PO
clubs Clan is marching I don't care if
Samir KH is you know agitating and
Inspire magazine as long as I can speak
as long as I can speak I know my ideas
are better I know that America America
beautiful beautiful America the first
government in the history of man the
first moral government based on
individual
rights this is such a concept that is
never taught in
school that has never understood what it
means centuries of blood and toil to
come to this magnificent moment in human
history and so what we witness always is
individualism versus collectivism always
if it wasn't stalinism it was communism
communism national socialism and now
it's uh polit it's Islamic Jihad it's
the same thing different costume this is
the gar of the Shahid same thing the in
you're fighting for individual rights
whatever your religion whatever your
belief system you're fighting for your
right to do it and to believe it and to
not tread on anybody else that's the
essence of the book the book will teach
you how to fight it even gives you your
talking points what to put on your signs
what to ask what to say because this
because you're being
played and American freedoms are being
destroyed they are being destroyed
slowly chip chip chip chip chipping away
and the media is the most dangerous
aspect they are the biggest weapon they
have in their Arsenal they're dangerous
I mean like I'm pointing out here with
the New York Post he became agitated
about anti there was no anti-muslim
backlash and this whole thing about
islamophobia let me tell you
something Abdul
Muhammad who was a prominent member of
The International Institute of Islamic
thought a Muslim Brotherhood group was
present when the what did you call it um
the thought Exterminating device
islamophobia was invented he said it was
invented and created in in the bowels of
Muslim think tanks as a device a thought
crushing device to uh bash any criticism
of Islam well it certainly has worked
has it not you can bash Christianity you
can bash Judaism you can make fun of pis
but you cannot say muhamad on sath you
cannot put him in a Huggy Bear costume
you cannot run the cartoons and where is
Molly Nars where where is Molly Nars how
many people in the no Molly narses okay
I see two two hands two hands two very
briefly because I don't even know if I'm
over my time and if I am I apologize
profusely and I haven't even touch I hav
I haven't even I haven't even scratched
the surface this what's so scary um very
briefly South Park did an episode and in
that episode they put because you can't
show Muhammad they put him in a Huggy
Bear
costume well there was a death threat
immediately issued on the heads there
was a fatwa death fatwa issued and some
little cartoonist in
Seattle a liberal she didn't know what
she was doing loves the show says let's
everybody draw muhamad day you know
thinking I guess they can't kill us all
right well within 24 hours there was a
fat on her
head she recanted you must never recant
by the way
ever never ever show weakness it's like
shocks to blood she recanted and the FBI
insisted that she' go into hiding at her
own expense her own expense lost her job
lost her name lost her life lost her
house and you don't even know who she is
America Molly Nar should be the poster
girl for free speech on the front page
of every newspaper and every news news
broadcast in America and people don't
know who she is but some little known
Pastor in some Backwater in Florida says
he's going to burn the Quran and they're
six you know 60 feet deep there the
media in uh by the dove Church
now I didn't agree with that by the way
just so that you know I'll take a bullet
for his right to do it because it's
protected
speech it's protected
spech I didn't like it CU you know we
don't burn books it's not what we do
Nazis burn books I didn't like it
because the antidote to bad speech is
more speech the antidote to bad speech
is given more give and take let to
discuss it no what winds up happening is
Bill O'Reilly has Kon regularly he's got
hakee Muhammad or as you might know him
Keith Ellison on you don't see waffer on
his show you don't see Robert Spencer
Ian War aan her Ali where are those
voices where are they I mean I get on
but I get on like a gorilla it's gorilla
Warfare like you have to come with me
cuz she's suing the MTA or you have to
cover me because of a whatever my bus
ads or you know my taxi ads you know I
was running tax a taxi campaign on top
of the taxis I was running the faces of
the girls in America who was who killed
an a of killings I had about eight
different ANS all beautiful girls am me
and Sarah noral
Malaki Hassan all and the Muslim Camp
drivers were taking off the the the um
the ads off the top of the
cabs what strikes me is that the the
taxi and limousine commission actually
removed ads for gentlemen's clubs
because Muslim drivers in New York York
wouldn't wouldn't wouldn't drive didn't
want them on there now you could say
well no it's just a girl looking
fetchingly you know and the name of the
club that's it now you can say well
she's insinuating whatever with her eyes
OH
police and cab drivers do not have to
ride in CS that's wrong that's the
Sharia So when you say the Sharia is not
happening it's happening everywhere the
media doesn't talk about uh Jihad
because they don't want to offend Islam
that's blasphemy laws I am demonized
marginalized because I speak critically
about Islam all of us that do this work
are rended radioactive you Google my
name you'd be like oh my God I I can't
believe I didn't get some kind of a
disease from this
girl what they make from me thank God my
parents would all like like to see it
I'm serious it's just unbelievable and
anybody knows that has gotten into this
fight I mean it's
like I mean I enjoy it now the meaner
they get the more I know I hit them I
love
it uh one other thing the teaching of
Arabic they wanted to make it mandatory
in certain Texas schools we need to
understand that in in
Islam Arabic is considered the language
of Heaven it's considered the language
of Allah because when Allah delivered
his message to Muhammad he delivered it
in Arabic and so you have to understand
that the expansion uh and the teaching
of Arabic is seen as a sphar head in the
Islamic imperialistic project and
anywhere that they're doing this um and
these Arabic schools also always wind up
becoming madrasas and these are taxpayer
funded schools I have no problem
teaching Arabic teach Chinese teach
Spanish make it an
elective this is what you have to fight
you must fight this wherever you see
this and you will begin now that you
have the the the glasses and that's what
this is I I I like to use the analogy
that the American people like Helen
Keller and somebody moved the
furniture because they know something's
happening but everyone's telling them no
no no no no shut
up and this is how they cowed the people
in Europe if you've been there you'll
know exactly what I'm saying so my point
in all this is you're a political
group and I am telling you that it is do
or die in
2012 if you think Obama and I wrote the
book preach it okay if you think Obama
was bad first term you ain't seen
nothing his Department of Justice is
suing suing New Jersey County because
the corrections facility said you have
to wear the uniform you have to wear the
the uniform of the corrections facility
wanted to wear the nikab wanted to wear
the uh hijab and now he's suing this New
Jersey County so the correction officers
can wear this gar you know don't be a
correction officer the cashiers at w
Walmart and a Target who refused to
handle meat that's not Halal you know
what don't be a cashier at Target and
Walmart but they won but they won Disney
they're suing to whether hijab or the
nikab Disney has a dress code since 1957
don't work at Disney I mean Disney is
nothing
sacred no nothing is sa and the more
iconic the bigger the fight and if
Disney's not iconic I don't know what
else is I iic of America but
Mickey this is what we see time and time
again so understand these things are not
happening in a vacuum it's part of a
project and you have to fight
it soldiers you
know because the soldiers know they know
you know they're they're there they're
fighting it they know and it must it
must be I I can't even imagine the
feeling that the the country has not
only forgotten about you but if you ask
Americans in the street in the schools
what are you fighting in Iraq what are
you fighting in Afghanistan they can't
answer you and it's not hard it's Jihad
what what what are we doing in
Afghanistan and the criminalizing of our
soldiers they should be brought up on
charges for that they should be brought
up on
chares to do the things that they're
doing with Rules of Engagement that are
so crippling ordinary men could never
ever succeed these are extraordinary
these are our
best and the strategy I think I I am
totally uh opposed to Obama's strategy
because I think he's setting our our our
boys up to be killed I do I said it as
far back as April 2009 it just doesn't
and yet still these are superheroes all
right all right tie them both back I'll
bite them to death you know you know
they it's just amazing support them
support them you don't know what they're
doing because when we leave there
believe me all those jihadis that
they're
killing I'm going to come home to roost
don't think for one second that it's
going to get better we have been killing
a lot of a lot of jihadists that's what
we're doing by the
way don't forget what we're doing there
and why we're doing it a is a
you can avoid reality but you cannot
avoid reality no one is going to save
you you need to understand this the
politicians are looking in the rearview
mirror we need politicians that will
speak to this subject not bash Muslims
no no no no no no but
certainly a to to to promise that unlike
Obama's doj who scuttled the
prosecutions of the Muslim Brotherhood
groups that were named as unindicted Co
conspira in the largest Hamas funding
trial in our nation's history that they
promise that they will pursue those
prosecutions that there will be a
separation of mosan state that people
that work for the government will be
vetted they will be vetted and if
they're tied to the Muslim Brotherhood
they will not be allowed to work in the
government that's right where more how
many people have to die how many people
how many attacks do we have to thwart I
mean that Time Square bomber have you
been to Time Square on a Saturday night
it's teaming with Humanity do you have
any idea how many people would have been
killed it would have made 911 look it
would have dwarfed
911 so so it's all okay because Hashem
said not tonight
fella is that where we are now operation
fetal
position that's what it
is that's not who we
are we're not Europe we're proud We have
civilizational self-esteem We Know Who
We Are
we're freedom and that's what we're
fighting for and that's what you have to
fight for